[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and we have an
interesting interview with Robert Downey
jr. coming out in the wake of comments
made by Martin Scorsese earlier in the
week Scorsese was asked what he thought
of the Marvel movies recently and the
world famous director had some pretty
big criticisms which included the
following honestly the closest I can
think of them as well made as they are
with actors doing the best they can
under the circumstances is theme parks
it isn't the cinema of human beings
trying to convey emotional psychological
experiences to another human being
when asked if he'd ever tried to watch
them Scorsese stated I tried you know
but that's not cinema now obviously
these comments are pretty controversial
and the Internet has gone absolutely
wild with them before we get into the
meat of the story though make sure you
hit the subscribe button on the channel
for daily breakdowns and all the latest
movies TV shows and more and drop a
thumbs up because it goes a long way to
making videos like this anyway our DJ
was asked on the Howard Stern Show what
his thoughts on Scorsese's comments were
and he had the following to say has
become the thing it is a huge moneymaker
yeah you still enjoy doing it yes I'll
tell you the truth I didn't expect it to
become what it became and it is this
very large multi-headed Hydra at this
point and I also I've always had other
interests and according to Scorsese it's
not cinema I got to take a look at that
you know what why did he say that
because it's his opinion and what it is
venema isn't it I mean it plays in
theaters yeah well what did he mean by
that that it's not cinema I appreciate
his opinion because I think it's like
it's like anything we need all of the
different perspectives so we can come to
Center and move on no this year a
Filipino come up you're terrified know
you've been to a two magnanimous yeah oh
really what were you insulted when he
said that it's not cinema that somehow
Iron Man is in cinema in
cinema to me well I mean look it'd be
like saying Howard Stern isn't Radio it
is it is it makes no sense what we see
jealous of the success it's not but I
mean he's Martin Scorsese
and what did he mean by it I think he in
his view and by the way there's a lot to
be said for how these genre movies and I
was happy to be part of the problem if
there is one right you know were
denigrated the the we are the era the
artform cinema and by the way when you
come in like a stomping Beast and you
eliminate the competition in such a
demonstrative way you know it's it's
phenomenal it is phenomenal
and maybe he's upset about the you know
what it is you get older you're used to
cinema being a certain way can I tell
you something yeah do you actually think
Martin Scorsese is upset about Marvel
movies yes yes I do because he's the guy
who's busy archiving films and he hasn't
survived my dad's films and Bobby I
appreciate this point of view Robin what
do you think yeah and why not I don't
know it's kind of a knock I mean the
fact is I don't were you ever nominated
for Academy Award for iron man now don't
you think that's a and be serious yeah
because it's a superhero movie they turn
their nose that the performance is
excellent well it is a totally
believable character well I'm so glad
you brought this up because there was
some talk about it and I said let's
let's not and because I'm much more like
you than you might really want to to
believe I listen to the show I agree
with most all of your opinions varied
though they may be occasionally you'll
go on some on some you know tributary
trail of thought that I go like that's
not how I see it but I go but I love the
okay so that's the full clip and I think
that downy takes a very dignified
response to the comments and it's quite
respectful towards Scorsese now this is
obviously because of the directors body
of work and it's difficult to argue with
someone of his stature about the state
of film when he's being so influential
in the genre however I do agree a lot
with what our DJ is saying and that I
feel like people in the industry feel
quite jealous of Marvel's success and
even earlier this week we had Jennifer
Aniston say that they drew in cinema
yeah cuz Along Came Polly did wonders
for the movie industry didn't it Jen
yeah anyway every time a comment like
this pops up by now the person and kind
of reminded of things that people said
when I was growing up which is that
comic books win heart now as I've gotten
older the medium has changed a lot and
there's so much respect in general for
comic books at the moment that it's very
difficult to refute that they on art now
of course Scorsese is entitled to his
opinion but I think the general reaction
is that he is wrong and that they are
indeed films and that moviemaking in
general has changed to go with the times
of course Scorsese is a genius but even
things like his upcoming project the
Irish Man which features a lot of D
aging
Oh something - the technology is
developed by the MCU another thing is
that score says he was asked about
Marvel movies in general and to the
uninitiated I'm sure all comic-book
movies get lumped in with them so
perhaps someone asked what he thought of
those Marvel movies and his mind went to
more like lustre entries such as the
amazing spider-man Dark Phoenix stuff
like that rather than the MCU we just
don't know but Kevin Feige had some
words on the statement as well saying
the following
maybe it's easy to dismiss the VFX or
flying people or spaceships or
billion-dollar grosses I think it is
easy to say that when you've already
been awarded in a certain way Alfred
Hitchcock never won Best Director so
it's very nice but it doesn't mean
everything I would much rather be in a
roomful of engaged fans which yeah I
feel like that's a perfect comment now
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on these statements and if you agree
with Martin Scorsese or think that the
Marvel movies are cinema comment below
and let me know and if you want to see a
breakdown of a calm
book film at Scorsese might approve of
that make sure you check out my
run-through of all the evidence that
points towards who joke is for your
father is this is the digital DNA test
and it's definitely worth checking out
if you want to know more you want to
come chat to me on Twitter make sure you
follow me at definition whitey and if
you want to join my discord that make
sure you click the link in the
description below you've got an awesome
community that's made up of people just
like you and it's the best way to stay
up to date with the channel so hopefully
I see you over there activist also just
want to let you know that are currently
giving away a free copy of spider-man
far from home on blu-ray and all you
have to do to be in with a chance of
winning it so liked this video make sure
that you subscribe to the channel and
leave your thoughts on Gemini man in the
comment section below the winner will be
chosen at random on October the 15th and
the blue rope doubt from then to ever
get surprised so best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]